pleasure to introduce this afternoon
speaker
stephen w mosher is president of the
population research institute
he was educated at the university of
washington at stanford university
he enlisted in the u.s navy and served
with the u.s
7th fleet eventually reaching the rank
of lieutenant
in 1979 he became the first american
social scientist
permitted to do field research in china
since the communist revolution
he has served as the director of the
asian studies center at the clermont
institute
and on the u.s commission on
broadcasting to the people's republic of
china
mr mosher has lectured at the u.s
special forces command
the national war college and the us
navy's
sea systems command he's the author or
editor of numerous books on china
including most recently bully of asia
why china's dream is a threat to the new
world
please join me in welcoming mr mosher
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone i'm happy to be
here at hillsdale college again
the crowd seems a little sparser than it
was last year
but that's only because we're all
socially distanced right there are many
people watching
online or from other locations
and the
i have a special place in my heart for
hillsdale college because it's led by
my good friend dr larry yarn with whom i
worked at
the clermont institute from 1986 to 1995
before going to washington
i'm here today to talk about
china as an election issue now up until
a few days ago
of course i think we all would have
agreed that china in one way or another
was probably the most important issue in
the election
and those who disagreed would have said
no no it's the economy
but the economy only takes pride of
place
because china unleashed some months ago
a pandemic on the world and shut down
the most vibrant economy
that the united states and the world i
think had ever seen
without that economic slowdown i don't
think there'd be any doubt about the
outcome of the election on november
third
and uh the pandemic of course was caused
by what
president trump rightly calls the china
virus
this is a virus that was created in a
chinese lab
overseen by the people's liberation army
and then deliberately released upon the
world
that is a topic for another day
but it's all true uh and it can be
documented we have
more and more studies coming out that
show this a lot of people don't want to
talk about it because of the
implications
of what i just said but nevertheless
uh that is that is what happened that's
the origin of the virus and that's the
responsibility for the threat the spread
of the virus rests entirely
with beijing and with senior leader core
leader
the new red emperor xi jinping himself
so the u.s economic setback of late
is china's responsibility as well so
again china is the most important issue
in the upcoming election or would have
been
until last week ruth
bader ginsburg supreme court justice
may god rest her soul was promoted to a
higher court
and turned the the political race upside
down
but we will get through the nomination
and confirmation of the next supreme
court justice i believe before the new
president
is uh is sworn in next january
and then we will return to
the preeminent challenge of our age
and that is the challenge posed by the
people's republic of china not just to
the united states but to the
peaceful beneficent world order that the
united states created after world war
ii and continues to oversee in important
ways
now in the interest of full disclosure i
happen to be a member of the advisory
group
for catholics for trump 2020
and uh actually was a member of the
advisory group for catholics for trump
in 2016
as well i was an early supporter
of donald trump for two reasons
both of which have to do with china
the first reason is life and
uh i was in china
in 1979 and 1980
as first american social scientist
allowed to do research behind the
bamboo curtain in 30 years i found
myself in the middle of the most
horrific population control program the
world has ever seen
you call it the one child policy that's
what it was publicly called
for the chinese people it was a program
of uh forced abortion for sterilization
forced contraception
i was present in the operating room when
they were forcibly aborting women at
seven eight and nine months
gestation by caesarean section
i became pro-life when i witnessed those
crimes
i think if you uh witness the killing of
a child
in the third trimester pregnancy and a
forced abortion
if you're not pro-life when you see this
you don't have a human heart beating in
your chest
so i was also an early supporter of the
president because of the china issue
writ large i have been a critic of the
people's republic of china since
1980. i became aware that uh
that president trump was also a critic
of the people's republic of china
at least since the late 1990s
when he criticized their currency
manipulation their cheating on trade
even in those early days
so for those two reasons i came to
support him back in 2016.
so i'm going to make three points today
i'm going to talk first about why and
how china is a threat
to the united states and then i'm going
to talk about the two candidates
and where they stand vis-a-vis china
now i don't need to tell this audience
i don't think that the people's republic
of china
under the chinese communist party is the
greatest threat this country has ever
faced
but i will anyway because the point
seems to be in some dispute in some
quarters
one presidential candidate fairly
recently said
that china's not our enemy it's merely a
competitor
quote unquote china is far more than a
competitor
let's start with the pentagon's latest
china military power report which came
out last week
this latest report notes the regime has
quote
marshalled the resources the technology
the political will over the last two
decades to strengthen and modernize its
army navy and air force in every respect
in fact china is already ahead of the
united states in certain areas
that's directly from the pentagon it
went on to say the
chinese communist party now controls the
world's largest
navy it is obsessively growing
its nuclear and missile arsenal
it warned the report did that the goal
of this military buildup is nothing less
than to quote
revise aspects of the international
order
revised aspects of the international
order is
an understatement
the chinese communist party is actually
trying to co-opt
undermine and replace the current world
order
with a cyanocentric one a world order in
which the
decisions about the future of the world
will be made
not in brussels or new york or in
washington d.c
but in beijing now
when this report was released
beijing was livid beijing is now
accusing washington of quote
hegemony and provocation
for telling the truth about its ever
more aggressive moves towards
what towards hegemony and provocation
now the
regime spokesman went on to say that
america is quote
the real destroyer of world peace and
said china's military buildup should not
worry any country because it quote would
not threaten
any country well
tell that to taiwan where you are now
seeing constant
incursions by the pla air force into
taiwan's airspace
tell that to uh india for example where
chinese troops continue to encroach on
the indian border
and there has been recent conflict tell
it to
kyrgyzstan one of the stands in central
asia
where china appears to have now
voiced a territorial claim to half the
country
china is moving in the wrong direction
the leader of china xi jinping has just
issued guidelines last week
telling nominally private businesses
that they must quote strengthen the
cultivation
of of their loyalty to the party
and and that young entrepreneurs must
always listen to
and follow the party every
nominally private company in china is
now going to have to have
a party sell in its ranks
and is going to have to have a chairman
of that or party secretary of that cell
sitting on the board of directors of the
company
now those of you who run for-profit or
non-profit companies
know that if you're sitting at one end
of the conference table
and a member of the chinese communist
party is sitting at the other end who
has the ultimate say
over the direction of the company uh
i think at the very least the communist
party now has
veto power over every company
uh in the country this marks of course a
radical
disappointment for those of us who
thought that the private sector of the
chinese economy
would continue to grow and blossom over
the decades
while the publicly owned sector of the
economy the state-owned sector of the
economy would naturally shrink
because of its inherent inefficiencies
because of its
misallocation of resources that's not
what's happening in china today that's
not what's been happening in china for
the last
20 years the pendulum has swung now
decisively in the other direction xi
jinping
is a communist first and foremost and
like all communists he wants to seize
control
in one mean by one means or another
of the means of production and this new
set of guidelines is a step
in that direction
so we have to be wary
of tick tock any deal about tick tock
that doesn't cut out chinese owners
the justice department just last week
unsealed indictments charging hackers
connected to china's intelligence
services with infiltrating
100 plus organizations around the world
including tech companies government
agencies
universities and manufacturers and they
did this to steal
intelligence and steal intellectual
property
this of course is just the tiniest tip
of the iceberg because there are
literally battalions
and i use the word battalion a military
term deliberately battalions
of hackers employed by various
intelligence
agencies including military intelligence
to hack into websites and servers around
the world to gather intelligence
and useful intellectual property the fbi
estimates that
china steals 600 billion
dollars a year in intellectual property
from the united states
multiply that over 10 years that's
6 trillion dollars and that's been going
on
now uh for decades the largest transfer
of wealth in human history
has been from the united states to china
of course while it's stealing
intellectual property
stealing intelligence and extorting cash
it is also setting itself up beijing is
as the savior of less developed
countries
it offers money and goods in exchange
for
sovereignty it's even exploiting the
pandemic that it caused to this
end right now china is offering
latin american and caribbean countries
one billion dollars in loans to buy
its vaccines when they become available
now that's a pretty good business plan
isn't it
you unleash a pandemic on the world
you destroy the early samples of the
vaccine that are held in private labs in
china
yet of course because you know the
genome of the vaccine
of the virus that you created you can
quickly develop a vaccine and then
instead of giving it to the world that
you've unleashed it on
you actually loan money to countries so
they can buy the vaccine
to cure the disease that you unleashed
on the world
you can't you can't make this stuff up
so we have as a result of
all of this malign activity towards the
united states and other countries
we have people like john ratcliffe the
director of national intelligence
warning us quote china poses a greater
national security threat to the u.s than
any other nation
the threat is economic it's military
and it's technological that includes
threats of election
influence and interference
of course it's not just a threat to the
united states it's a threat to
great britain canada france all of the
countries of the world especially the
democratic countries even if some of our
allies
still pretend otherwise
now we still have because we're in this
curious election year mental state
we still have people like andrew mccabe
the former deputy director of the fbi
and adam schiff
and john brennan saying that our chief
danger in the world is russia
russia russia when in fact it is
china china china
and has been for the past two decades
china is a greater threat than russia by
at least an order of magnitude and the
disparity between russia
and china is growing
and unlike russia china is a threat
across all domains
not just military but economic and
technological as well
now my friend peter navarro who's been
in the white house since the beginning
of the trump administration likes to
list what he calls
china's seven deadly sins
peter says that china needs to stop
stealing
our intellectual property stop forcing
technology transfers
you want to do business in china you
have to transfer your technology into
the hands of the chinese government
which oftentimes promptly sets up a
competing
factory using the same technology that
you've just transferred
peter also says we need we need to stop
china from hacking our computers
china needs to stop dumping goods at
below market prices into our markets
and china needs to stop putting our
companies out of business
china needs to stop state-owned
enterprises from receiving
heavy subsidies and china needs to stop
exporting fentanyl uh to the united
states which kills tens of millions
tens of thousands of americans each year
china also needs he says to stop
currency manipulation
of course peter navarro's seven deadly
sins mostly
address china's economic sins against
the united states except for the
fentanyl issue
but there are many other sins that china
is committing against the u.s led
order as well against the u.s political
system
and against americans themselves
china has made as most of you know
enormous
and destabilizing claims in the south
china sea
uh their claims in the south china sea
are roughly equivalent to the us
claiming the entire entire caribbean as
sovereign u.s territory
china also is encroaching along the
indian border
it is making a claim against the country
of kyrgyzstan that it owns the pamir
mountain range which is basically the
the the eastern half of the country
it also claims that it owns not just the
senkaku islands which are japanese
territory but it also
owns okinawa and the entire ryukyu chain
as well
that's the chain of islands stretching
from the southern japanese home island
of kyushu down to taiwan
why does it claim okinawa because in in
1778 the daimyo the
shogun in charge of okinawa sent tribute
to the qing imperial court which were
evermore locked in okinawa as a
tributary state of
of china it is also
a senior chinese official astonishing
the world recently pointed out
that up until the unequal treaty with
russia between china and russia of 1860
china had owned vladivostok and the
russian far east as well
i'm sure vladimir putin wasn't happy to
hear that
maybe that's one reason why russia is
currently moving additional troops
to the area as we meet today
obviously any territorial claims
unresolved territorial issues are
destabilizing
but for china it seems to be all in a
day's work it has made territorial
claims against
most of its uh immediate neighbors
specifically on the election of course
bill barr was here last week
both the attorney general william barr
and national security adviser robert
o'brien have recently remarked that it
is
not russia but china that has taken
quote the most active role
in interfering in the u.s elections
and i just want to go over a couple
things that china is actually
doing in this regard because most people
don't know the extent
of china's election interference most of
it occurs
uh on on on the internet
but some things are are quite open the
global times which is the english
language newspaper uh run by the chinese
communist party
uh recently published an article saying
that uh
that most leaders in the world before
prefer
job that joe biden be elected as
president of the united states because
joe biden is smoother than donald trump
well uh then china has what it calls
uh the wu mao army wu mao is 50 cents
in in chinese and the chinese communist
party
hires hundreds of thousands of people
to propagate the party line both inside
of china and outside of china it pays
them
50 cents a posting
now you can't become wealthy making 50
cents a posting but i guess you can make
a good living
and so the wu mao army is waging
information warfare against us trying to
manipulate their election i have a
a twitter account uh unfortunately
but i had to open it a couple years ago
because of
because of the the rising threat from
china
and i get postings from the wu mao army
on my twitter account it's the most
ridiculous thing
that you can imagine the wumau army is
not particularly fluent in english and
so it's pretty obvious when
uh when it comes from china it's crude
but i think with some people it can be
it can be effective
and they're posting you know they're
they're getting paid to troll
our internet with anti-trump pro-biden
messages
social media is a tool that the
communist party is using to influence
what's going on here
so the uh we also have the director of
the national counterintelligence and
security center
william evannina saying that we assess
that china prefers that president trump
does not win reelection we also know
that there are
so there are spam dissemination networks
that
are paid for set up by the chinese
communist government
that set up a large number of fake
accounts uh that
have launched violent attacks on
president trump on social media
we also know and and i was involved in
in setting up radio free asia many years
ago radio free asia recently published
an article asserting that
the reason that we closed down
the houston consulate of the people's
republic of china
was because chinese military
intelligence
was using it as a base to recruit
militants for antifa
and blm activities contributing of
course to the unrest that
uh that apparently china hoped would
lead to trump's defeat in november
and then there was the video of chinese
speaking rioters outside the white house
a few weeks ago who when people began to
notice them
were ordered by their leader to withdraw
speaking perfect mandarin chinese
so um all of this
election interference i think makes
anything that russia is doing
look childish it's much more
sophisticated
and much more pervasive
so now that we've established that china
is the principal threat to the us-led
world order
and to democracy in the united states
interfering with our election in a way
that
vladimir putin could only dream of of
having done
we need to look at the two candidates
now last week the new york times
released a 3100 word story
entitled joe biden's china journey
the three authors of the piece engaged
in an effort to explain
the former vice president's long
relationship
with the people's republic of china and
at the end of the article they suggested
that
the current democratic nominee
is ready to get really really tough on
china tougher even
than donald trump now
i've known joe biden for a long time
and in my view biden has appeased china
and advanced its interests for as long
as i've been paying attention to him
and indeed as long as i've been
interested in china policy
which is to say shortly after he arrived
in washington in 1973 and i arrived in
hong kong
with the u.s 7th fleet
i think american workers and the
american economy have paid a heavy
price for the combination of naivete
and greed that has driven his views of
china over the decades
the naivete came first of course the
greed came later
in the 90s biden pushed for and
repeatedly voted to protect
china's most favored nation trading
status
and that ensured that chinese made goods
would flood america's big box stores
we've most favored nation status
was up for review every year in the 80s
and 90s
and it was used as leverage by the
united states
to try and get political prisoners in
china released
for example to try to get china to move
in the direction
of respecting human rights and and a
more open society
we gave all that up uh in the late 1990s
senator biden was also a champion of
china's entry into the world trade
organization
under terms that heavily favored the
communist giant
china was allowed into the world trade
organization under terms that treated it
as a less developed country which meant
that
while it had free access to american
markets
it could restrict access to its own this
blunder
has cost the u.s 60 000 factories and
three and a half million jobs
now senator biden did all this despite
admitting that the prc had a quote
reprehensible record on human rights
and unfair trade practices but with
people in washington of course you have
to look beyond the rhetoric and see what
they actually do
and senator biden's actions with regard
to beijing have
obviously benefited china and in more
recent years his family
now one of the points made by the new
york times
authors was that he was a strong
advocate
in the early 1990s of setting up radio
free asia radio free asia
is a radio free broadcast service that
broadcasts news and information
into china about events in china itself
bypassing bypassing state
censorship and control so that when
labor unrest occurs when villagers
are upset because their land has been
confiscated by the local communist party
secretary when
uh people demonstrated against the one
child
policy enforced abortions when episodes
like this occurred in china radio free
asia would
report on it broadcast it into china so
the chinese people would know
what was happening in their own country
now senator biden's defenders
claim that he was instrumental in
establishing this federally funded news
network
to promote democratic values within
china
one of his senate foreign relations
committee aides of the time james rubin
told the new york times
that senator biden worked hard to set up
radio free asia because he realized that
china was a brutal system
after the 1989 crackdown against
protesters around tiananmen square
the 1989 crackdown against protesters
around tiananmen square was brutal
it resulted in the deaths of at least 10
000 people
in beijing we estimate and to make
matters worse
the day after the protest was put down
army
columns of army trucks pulled up in
front of the hospitals and
medical clinics in beijing and all of
the wounded were taken
away um
most never to be heard from again
so when you ex want to expunge the
memory of
a debacle like the chennai man square
massacre
you you have to destroy the evidence
the evidence that these wounded were
carrying on their very bodies
not all of those who worked with biden
at the time however were that
impressed with his efforts on radio free
asia
i served as commissioner of the
presidential executive commission on
broadcasting to the prc in the early 90s
i served alongside of two commissioners
hand-picked by
senator biden both of senator biden's
commissioners fought against the
establishment of radio free asia every
step of the way
and in the end both of them voted
against it
the vote at the end of the day to
establish radio free asia was very very
a very close-run thing it was six to
five biden's commissioners were on the
wrong side
we met with senator biden later to try
and shore up his support for radio free
asia
he sort of laughed off the defection of
his two commissioners
he talked about his personal support for
the project
and he said it just shows how
open-minded and objective i am that my
both of my commissioners
voted the wrong way that's not the way i
read it
it showed to my way of thinking it
showed that he was asleep at the switch
so
what you get with many politicians is
rhetoric and no action
so uh radio free asia was established
uh in 1994 and the senators who
um godfathered it were senator jesse
helms and john mccain
not not senator joe biden
so then we have the
september 2000 debate over whether or
not to grant most
permanent most favored nation status to
china
we also had china's accession to the
world trade organization
we also have you know the the
the myth that has been believed by many
in the foreign policy establishment
until recent years
and the myth was that china's rise was
not only
inevitable that that the united states
should welcome it
biden said along with many people in the
90s and in the early years of this
century that quote a rising china
is an incredibly positive development
for not only china
but for the united states and the rest
of the world
what a difference a pandemic makes
as vice president biden's efforts to
enable china's rise
accelerated in may 2013 he helped to
engineer
a memorandum of understanding
that exempted the people's republic of
china's corporations from u.s security
statutes and regulations
this means that over the last seven
years
the chinese communist party has raised
trillions of dollars
from our debt and equity markets on
preferential terms
giving them an advantage over american
firms
how so because the memorandum of
understanding that he
negotiated as vice president exempted
chinese companies
listed in u.s stock exchanges from
independent audits allowing them to
continue to
cook their books while raising billions
from unsuspecting u.s
investors it is um
commonly known in china that companies
keep two or three sets of books
they keep one set of books for the
public
and for naive foreigners they keep a
second set of books
for their chinese partners and then the
principal owner will keep a set of books
so he knows exactly how much money he's
making
so this memorandum of understanding
which we're now trying to get
rid of gave chinese
companies exemptions from the kind of
oversight
that allowed them to hide the risk that
investing in them posed to u.s investors
on the human rights front vice president
biden was largely missing in action when
he did speak out in public it was to
soft pedal
chinese communist party abuses he said
on one visit to china
that he understood quote unquote the
need for the brutal one-child policy
as an eyewitness to that brutal one
child policy
i i found that comment unfathomable
he was also nominally in charge of what
we call the pivot to asia which was
announced in 2011
and was our effort to reorient our
forces to face the challenge of the 21st
century which is
the challenge of china
to counter china's continuing military
buildup yet as china militarized the
south china sea
and bullied smaller neighbors such as
the philippines and vietnam
into accepting its claims by the time
that the obama biden administration had
left office
we had added exactly one warship to the
seventh fleet
which is hardly an impressive pivot in
my view
now i'm not even going to talk about why
he took his son hunter
to beijing in december 2013 everyone i
think knows that story
um what i would like to
to to conclude with uh in talking about
the former vice president
is his comments since leaving office
even as the danger from a rising china
opposed
that a rising china poses to the u.s has
become more and more apparent
the former vice president has continued
to apologize
for the prc he has repeatedly in
speeches over the last few years
dismissed or downplayed china's threat
to american national security
and to american jobs he claimed as
recently as last year that china
the chinese communist party said they're
not bad folks and they're not
competition
he did recently say that they are our
competitor which is a step in the right
direction but they are much much more
than a competitor
they are a threat to the united states
and to the world
so given the many many ways that china
has harmed american businesses
and workers by intellectual property
theft by forced technology transfer
currency manipulation
dumping below cost predatory pricing by
state-owned enterprises
widespread use of slave labor slave
labor
slave labor we have in the western part
of china
we have a minority about 12 million
strong of
turkish speaking uyghurs
and china under xi jinping has decided
that the
minorities in china must be eliminated
not physically eliminated we're not
hurting they're not hurting
the minorities into the gas chambers
but eliminated uh eliminated culturally
and so what's being done in what's
called eastern turkistan by the people
who live there
is this between one and three million
uyghur men are now in concentration
camps
the chinese communist party which has a
way with words calls them vocational
training camps
they're forced to work for free and in
the evenings after a long
day of working in textile mills or other
factories pollute producing goods for
export
to the united states and other countries
they then are forced to
endure mandatory study sessions where
they are taught
chinese and taught of course the
the the sayings of uh supreme leader xi
jinping
they are allowed the men are allowed one
hour a week to cry
that's that's sounds like a joke doesn't
it but it's not
one hour a week they're allowed to cry
for their for the wife or the children
that they're missing
to cry any other time is a sign of
insubordination and will be punished
as for the children the younger children
are often sent to boarding schools uh
where they're allowed to call home once
a month in the boarding school of course
the language of instruction is chinese
not turkish and there's no mention of
the islamic faith or the heritage of the
the cultural heritage of the
of the uyghur people as far as the
the older adolescents and young people
are concerned
the unmarried ones are being sold
to factories on the east coast of china
in lots of a hundred
you can order them in lots of a hundred
you needn't worry about their strange
dietary habits after all their turkeys
not chinese so they they have they like
to eat different things because they
come with their own cooks
and you need to worry about security
because they come with their own police
detachment
all you have to provide is a factory
dormitory inside the factory compound
that has to be surrounded by a high
fence the uyghur
workers are allowed out on sunday
afternoon for a few hours but only under
escort
i think that qualifies as slave labor
and then of course you have the women
and a few small children left at home
they're not left alone however about a
million
chinese police uh and officials have
been billeted with the women and small
children
at home there was a recent story that
came out by one
woman who escaped from eastern turkistan
about the
the sexual violence being visited on the
women
so you have the men in prison the women
being compromised the
the young adults being sold to slave
labor and the small children being
successfully i think probably cynicized
the goal clearly is to eliminate the
uyghurs as as a people
weaker have been around for a long time
several thousand years but they may not
be
around for much longer because of this
deliberate
forced effort at uh at cynicization same
thing is being done
uh to some degree in the mongol speaking
regions
of china in the north and in tibet in
the south where
the teaching of the tibetan language
even in the elementary school the
teaching of the mongolian language even
in the elementary school is now
forbidden
the children are to learn chinese
so um you know we we could talk for a
long time about the human rights abuses
in china but that's not the point of the
talk today
uh fewer and fewer people outside of
china regard china's rise as anything
but a disaster
for america and for the world more and
more people understand that china is
carrying out what it calls unrestricted
warfare
against the united states across all
domains
except the kinetic okay there was a book
called
unrestricted warfare published in 1999
by two senior pla colonel strategists
called unrestricted warfare
and it argued that the people's republic
of china should be
constantly warring against united states
it should be using all the means at its
disposal it should be sending
deadly drugs to the united states to
weaken the u.s
we see that in the shipments of fentanyl
it should be constantly stealing uh
launching cyber attacks stealing
personal data and
intellectual property from the united
states um
again china has been at war with the
united states across all domains for
decades
except the kinetic we're not firing
bullets at each other
but in every other way that the chinese
communist party can
the chinese communist party is trying to
weaken the united states with the goal
of
ultimately destroying it
now unfortunately
um we have
fortunately we have one candidate for
president who understands the threat
from china and i think
initially donald trump saw the threat as
principally economic
right the dumping of chinese-made goods
the currency manipulation the cheating
on trade
since the pandemic of course he sees it
as a threat
which it properly is across all domains
we have another candidate who says
however that he's going to
end the tariffs on chinese-made goods
he's going to not hold
communist china accountable for
unleashing the
china virus on the world but is
attempting to blame
trump for the outbreak
he is going to
cooperate according to his plan
with china in three areas
in climate change non-proliferation and
health security
are three areas that presidential
candidate joe biden says that we can
cooperate with
china now all three of these areas are
well by their sell by date
okay joe biden may be
committed to shut down every last
coal-fired plant in the united states in
the name of curbing
climate change but china is just as
determined to continue building them
china is opening a new coal-fired power
plant every two weeks or so
so what's there to discuss china will
continue doing that
china was exempted from the chinese from
the paris climate accords by the way
so uh the rules that would apply to us
the rules that would hamstring our
economy
did not apply to china working with
china on
nuclear and missile non-proliferation
agreements
almost sounds like a serious policy
proposal
until you realize that beijing is
probably the worst proliferator of both
in the world today pakistan north korea
and iran are among the known
beneficiaries of china's
assistance in these areas and finally
working with china on health security
sounds like a parody given that china
deliberately
unleashed a deadly virus on the world
and continues to lie about it to the
present day
so um we now approach the november
election
joe biden has finally begun cautiously
denouncing china as a dictatorship
a dictatorship which is kind of like
calling a category 5 hurricane a
summer breeze
the high-tech tyranny that dominates the
chinese people and even dreams of
extending its writ to the entire world
is like no other adversary
the united states has ever encountered
the chinese communist party is like all
communist parties a war party
that is to say the party itself is
organized along military lines
and is inherently expansionist its
leaders have long understood that there
are irreconcilable differences between
china and the united states
between what it calls socialism with
chinese characteristics
and free market democracy there are
irreconcilable differences between
the current u.s dominated international
order and the cynocentric one that
beijing hopes will replace it
that means that there is no win-win
scenario
involving democratic china democratic
america
and communist china they're only
temporary truces
the new cold war between china and the
united states is a zero-sum game
which will only be resolved when one
system decisively triumphs
over the other china
has been in a cold war with us
at least since 1991 when
then senior leader deng xiaoping said
to his fellows the old cold war is over
the soviet union has been defeated the
new cold war has begun
and china will defeat the united states
but i would say that the cold war
basically goes back to the founding of
the people's republic of china
because even as early as 1958
then chairman mao zeton
set up an earth control committee in the
senior ranks of the chinese communist
party
he was convinced that his great leap
forward would lead to
rapid modernization in china and that he
was
already looking beyond china's borders
to the day when
it would hold sway over asia and much of
the rest of the world so this has been
in the minds of of uh leaders in china
for a long long time
i think that
president trump post-pandemic now
understands this
i think that um vice president biden
although he's moving in the right
direction
does not i'm afraid that that
one candidate if elected would try to
restore the
status quo ante the one that heavily
favored china
for the last 25 years
the other of course will continue
the current policy of isolating
china there are alliances being formed
against china right now china by
releasing a pandemic on the world has
done more
in the last six months to unite the
world against it
than any american president could have
done over the course of a decade
india japan australia
even new zealand the philippines taiwan
are all coming together in various ways
to defend themselves against this new
menace
i think that an asian nato
is now for the first time
a realistic possibility building on the
quadrilateral
discussions that we're currently having
between australia india
japan and the united states we need
such an alliance we need such an
alliance to counter
the greatest threat facing the world
today the people's
republic of china thank you
thank you dr mosher we now have time for
some q a
if you have a question please make your
way to a microphone
hello as we re-evaluate our
relationship with china what if any
are some positive aspects to our
relationship that we should maintain
as we re-evaluate
i'm i'm sorry i'm supposed to be looking
over here
yes and and the question was
as we re-evaluate our relationship with
china
what are some positive aspects that we
ought to keep in mind
uh we ought to keep in mind that the
chinese people
are the first and foremost victims of
the chinese communist party the 92
million
members of the chinese communist party
eat drink and and feast
on the hard work and entrepreneurial
spirit
of the chinese people the chinese
communist party produces nothing in
terms of wealth
it's estimated by chinese economists
inside of china who got in trouble for
saying this by the way
that the chinese communist party
consumes about
one and a half trillion dollars in
wealth about 10 percent of the country's
gdp
every year in its salaries in its
offices in its homes in its
villas resorts foreign trips chauffeured
limousines and so forth all of the perks
that go along with holding power over
the chinese people
so we must never forget that the chinese
communist
party has victimized its own people
first and foremost
i mentioned the one child policy but if
we go back
and we total up the number of people
killed in the land reform
in the various anti-rightist campaigns
of the 1950s
in the great leap forward in the
cultural revolution in the famine that
followed the great leap forward where 42
and a half million people died
that's 42 and a half million
people died of starvation if we go total
up the total number of victims in china
the chinese communist party the number
excluding uh the number of babies
aborted
is probably around a hundred million so
that's what we need to keep in mind we
also need to keep in mind that the
chinese people
on taiwan have succeeded
where the chinese people on the mainland
have not in setting up a full-fledged
democracy
and so we know the chinese people are
capable
of democracy if we could simply
help end the misrule of the chinese
communist party on the mainland
that of course taiwan is a beacon
of freedom for the chinese people which
is precisely why
the chinese communist party is so
determined to crush it
hong kong was also such a beacon of
freedom for the chinese people
which is why this year we have seen
day after day the crushing of freedoms
in hong kong the tearing up of the
agreement between
china and great britain that was
supposed to preserve the freedom and
social and economic system in hong kong
for the next 30 years
is now gone by the wayside so
we must be very careful to distinguish
between the party
and and the people
sir i'm aware or i should say i know
that you are aware
of the fact that we have unwittingly
invested a tremendous amount of money in
china
i you mentioned the sec issue
but one of the things that concerns me
is we have so
many investment organizations
for instance the retirement programs
i'm from wisconsin wisconsin has a
tremendous amount
of money invested in china calpers
is at one time was actually being
managed by
a chinese and and they only
realized what was going on because they
too have a tremendous amount of
money we're talking about trillions not
millions or billions trillions of
dollars that are
financing things in china including
companies that are owned by the chinese
military
right how can we do something to
get them de-listed as a first step
and how can we get these managers of all
these retirement programs
to get rid of these things
well we should your point is very well
taken the chinese
communist party has profited enormously
by the investments from various
retirement funds in the united states
and we're working hard to try to end
that that uh that flow of money to china
china has a controlled currency
china needs hard dollars in order to
carry out its military modernization
program
in order to loan money to caribbean and
latin american countries so it can buy
the chinese-made vaccine to cure the
chinese-made virus for example
it needs access to hard currency and we
by giving it access to our capital
markets have have literally
enabled it to have access to trillions
of dollars
a number of us have been working to stop
this
we did get the the um uh steven mnuchin
secretary of the treasury and uh and and
others involved in an effort to stop the
federal retirement thrift corporation
from investing
federal retirement funds in in chinese
corporations
for reasons that i've already outlined
because those those uh those
corporations are not subject to the same
rules uh governing american corporations
when it comes to
having regular audits when it comes to
revealing the risk to
to to shareholders of investing in those
those those particular stocks and bonds
so we have to do more we have to to
solve this problem at the state level as
well
because it's literally as if the united
states
is is is donating blood
to china unit
after unit keeping the chinese communist
party's enterprise
uh flush with funds and if we were to
cut off
that that uh capital transfusion
i think the chinese communist party
would shortly find itself
uh in in even worse straights than it is
the debt levels in china are enormous we
don't know exactly how high they are
uh the debt that's on the books is is uh
almost 300 percent of gdp but we know
there's a lot of debt off the books
off the books debt is is incurred by
local governments by
by township by county officials who
engage in secret deals
that benefit themselves and their
cronies so there's
a tremendous amount of debt in china
eventually that
that debt will prove unsustainable
especially if we cut off access to uh
to u.s financial markets the other thing
that you can say in this regard is that
now that china is no longer a separate
entity in in in economic terms
there's no reason why the hong kong
dollar should be allowed to be
traded no country is allowed to have two
currencies
right the united states only has one
currency the u.s dollar
china now effectively has two it has the
renminbi which is not
uh freely convertible and it has the
hong kong dollar which
is uh the hong kong dollar should be
should be ended um there's they're using
they're going to be using uh let's see
with the
the uh alibaba is announcing
uh a um 30 billion dollar stock offering
for its investment group ant ant
which will be offered on the hong kong
stock exchange and there are lots of
american financial firms that are eager
to get their hands on the 300 million
dollars in commissions
that will result from from selling that
offering
but again hong kong is no longer a
separate entity hong kong
should not be allowed to be used in this
way by china by the chinese communist
party on the one hand as it crushes the
freedom of the people of hong kong
on the other it continues to use hong
kong to drain
resources from the united states and and
the west
to support its uh its project of
i want to domination back to something
you said right there at the beginning of
your talk regarding
the effect that the pandemic had on the
world economy
the i want to make a distinction here
and see if you can clarify on this point
but the reality is these lockdowns and
the the economic damage was caused by
the american government
and state officials who restricted
businesses who lock people in their
homes who restricted travel
that wasn't something that xi jinping or
the communist chinese regime did that
was something our regime did and so in
light of that can we really say
that the chinese regime is the greatest
threat facing america
when you have politicians in this
country who are the ones who are
actually implementing
the policies that are constraining the
freedom of everyday americans
well i think that's a very interesting
point and very well put
um but i i would i would answer by
saying
that that uh there's probably enough
blame to go around here
given given the dramatic health and
economic consequences of what we've seen
since the beginning of the year but the
majority of the blame the lion's share
of the blame obviously
belongs with china i think it's very
clear i was
i've been investigating this since it
began uh
in um in china uh late last year
and um i've also some of you may have
seen dr
yen lee hmong who is a whistleblower
from china a leading virologist who's
come out with
information about the how the virus was
designed
in the lab in wuhan wuhan institute of
virology and then spread
throughout the world planes from wuhan
were not allowed to fly to other chinese
cities but planes from
wuhan filled with passengers some of
whom
were unknowingly infected with the wuhan
virus
were allowed to fly to new york and san
francisco and milan and
and so forth so china deliberately
spread
the pandemic china also kind of set the
tone in this way
remember um it locked down
the city of wuhan and and the surround
most of the surrounding province
the the largest quarantine in human
history
about 50 million people right in that
immediate area were placed under
quarantine
and we saw pictures of people
dropping dead in the streets of wuhan
right
uh those those uh that footage was
allowed out of china we saw the
crematoria running 24 hours a day seven
days a week trying to
dispose of the bodies of those who died
so
everything that we were told by
the by beijing and by the world health
organization which was a co-conspirator
in in uh in uh in this matter
was that this was not only a very
infectious disease but an
extraordinarily
deadly disease and that we had no choice
but to follow
china's example in in in engaging in
complete lockdowns
so china set the tone in this and and of
course some
some some of our state governors have
followed but there's enough blame to go
around i mean
look at the 10 000 deaths in nursing
homes in new york
entirely unnecessary the deaths of
thousands in nursing homes in
in new jersey and pennsylvania so um
i'm not going to let american
politicians off the hook on that i
i think that they did overreact on the
basis of information on the basis of
inflated projections
my goodness nile ferguson the university
college of london
had a garbage algorithm that predicted
two million deaths
and being a widely respected
epidemiologist
when dr burks and deborah burks and
dr anthony fauci heard that that there
the the uk might suffer 500 000 deaths
and the
algorithm showed that the us might
suffer 2 million deaths from this
this china virus they went to see
president trump and they said you know
we must do everything we can
to stop the spread of this disease
because millions of american lives are
at risk
that was the information we were given
so you know you can only operate on the
best best science the best information
you have and there's been an awful lot
of misinformation about this
this china virus from the beginning